(indistinct chatter)
It is my duty to teach young generation
about the experience in a performance.
And I really think this
is a part of my work
as an artist; a kind of
duty and responsibility.
- She is probably one of the best teachers
I've ever had, in just this one week.
- So there's always
that suspended animation
not quite knowing what to expect next.
- And her criticism can be, it goes down
with a spoonful of honey,
literally for some people,
but it really does come from a place where
she is not taking, she's just giving.
And with a lot of people,
artists especially, that get to
a level like, "Oh, I'm having
my own show at the MoMA",
can get that important feeling
when you're around them.
She relates to you like we're all just
children in the playground.
- Performance is all about the dialogue,
energy dialogue, and being
present in here and now.
Audience is like a dog;
they can feel immediately
that you are afraid;
that you are insecure;
that you're not in the
right state of mind.
And they just leave; all tension is gone.
- Learning my potential for concentration,
Marina really showed us how to find it.
- The challenges really,
to maintain this level of
mind and body cleanse, and
she's definitely given us
the tools to be able to do
that when the time comes.
But these are things that are gonna be
very challenging in New York City.
- She already put us
through much more difficult
circumstances than we will
face in the performance.
I'm not gonna wait until
my first performance date
to see what's it's like
to stand for 2 1/2 hours.
- It's real lots of work to do
with yourself and your mind.
And people think, "Oh, that's easy,
just standing there and that's it."
But it's not like that.
It's very much demanding.